françois el bacha bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france vous
êtes au liban ces images vous les avez
vu le monde entier a les yeux rivés sur
beyrouth les libanais doivent être sous
le choc ce matin
racontez-nous comment vous vous avez
vécu ces événements tragiques hier en
fin de journée
écoutez je venais bonjour que d'abord je
venais d'arriver chez moi et puis il ya
eu un premier tremblement pensais que
c'était un tremblement de terre j'ai
juste pris le téléphone et jallet dehors
sécurité et d'un seul coup il ya eu une
très grosse explosion et pourtant je
suis à 6 km de l'or et voilà la première
réaction c'était de dire que c'était un
attentat un attentat proche donc sortir
voir wesk wesh ce que ça pouvait être
mais en fait c'était beaucoup plus loin
et puis petit à petit d'abord il y avait
des informations qui étaient assez
contradictoires sont parlé d'un attentat
au centre-ville d'une explosion à de
chameau et ensuite c'est à dire un peu
plus loin et après on a commencé à
savoir que c'était réellement dans le
port de beyrouth
et ce matin comment se sont réveillés
les libanais il ya des libanais qui
n'ont même pas pu aller qui n'ont pas pu
rejoindre leur maison vitraux cassés il
ya des immeubles ruinés comment est-ce
que les libanais se réveille aujourd'hui
après sept 7 nuits difficiles
déjà il y en a pas beaucoup qui ont
dormi
aujourd'hui les gens sont groggy et ça
ils savent pas à quoi s'attendre
demain le liban en ce moment cumul
catastrophe sur catastrophe
et ça c'est la dernière en date
maintenant sur beyrouth les dégâts sont
importants
certains quartiers sont effectivement
inaccessible le haut conseil supérieur
de la défense a préconisé
[Musique]
dix ans voire de contrôler toute la
sécurité pour éviter les vols et des
choses comme ça il ya encore beaucoup de
personnes qui qui serait disparu on
pense qu'ils seraient saoulés des
contres hier soir encore le dans l'effet
de souffle de l'explosion
beaucoup il ya des corps qui ont été
projetés en l'air l'armée libanaise est
en train de l'est les repêchés étaient
en train du moins de les repêcher
jusqu'à 4 heures du matin donc pour le
moment on est dans une sorte d'attentes
rapport le rapport à tout ça on his on
n'arrive pas encore à réaliser l'ampleur
du drame
je vous sens ému on a vu ces images au
liban de d'hôpitaux des scènes
d'apocalypse avec des gens qui sortaient
de l'hôpital en sanglante et comment
est-ce que selon vous le liban va faire
face à cette catastrophe qu'est ce que
le gouvernement a proposé pour le moment
c'est le gouvernement va se réunir
aujourd'hui c'est le conseil suprême de
la défense qui s'est réuni hier ils ont
déjà vos lui ils ont déjà alloué une
cent mille milliards de livres
libanaises pour les familles des
victimes et les dégâts
ils ont déclaré beyrouth ville sinistrée
de la sécurité maintenant ch aux mains
aux mains de l'armée libanaise
ça c'est pour les mesures principales la
question qui est plus important c'est
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire les
dégâts ya probablement plus de 2
milliards de d 2 milliards de dégâts au
port mais le port c'était la principale
porte d'entrée de marchandises
essentielles pour le blé pour la farine
pour les médicaments est déjà en été en
manque de stock
donc y'a les victimes on doit pleurer
des victimes on doit pleurer les morts
on doit soigner les victimes
et il ya aussi la suite et c'est la
suite qui
qui est qui semble être qui va être très
difficile vu ce qui se passe déjà du
point de vue économique le nitrate
d'ammonium serait désigné comme étant à
l'origine de ces explosions enquête elle
est toujours en cours pour l'instant ce
matériau il a été laissé dans cet
entrepôt près du port comment elle
expliqué est ce une négligence du
gouvernement il ya d'après autant
d'après ce qu'on a pu entendre ya un
litige commercial à l'origine de ce
stockage
le navire la marchandise a été saisie à
bord d'un navire en très mauvais état en
ils ont transporté cette marchandise
dans le port de beyrouth
le bateau lui-même qui était également
saisie a coulé un an plus tard à cause
justement de ceux de cet état lamentable
après cela normalement la marchandise
aurait dû être réacheminés par ce par
ses propriétaires en afrique
sauf que il refusait de payer une somme
à ce qu'on dit le 200 mille dollars pour
le faire
donc ça c'est pour le moment ce concept
là dessus après il ya la controverse les
gens entendent un avion est ce que c'est
une explosion due au nitrate d'ammonium
est ce que c'est un bombardement a
priori pour le moment c'est la thèse du
nitrate d'ammonium qui est privilégiée
par les autorités
le liban a vécu des épreuves très
difficiles ces dernières décennies il ya
aussi ce contexte de de covile 19 qui ne
facilite pas les la situation au liban
en ce moment selon vous comment est-ce
que le pays va se relever
il ya des aides humanitaires qui
arrivent d'un peu partout il ya la
france aussi qui va qui va aider comment
est-ce que le liban va va renaître de
ses cendres si je puis dire
économiquement le liban il est en
récession depuis 2018
il lui est impossible de s'en sortir
seul
il faut l'aide de la communauté
internationale et des négociations avec
le fmi était en cours
justement pour accéder à ces derniers
internationale mais on fait face à
certains
à certains obstacles il peut pas s'en
sortir seul la question ce soir est de
savoir d'où on pourra obtenir l'aide
la france a proposé son aide les pays
arabes sont en train d'acheminer une
aide ça c'est pour l'aide immédiate
l'aide à long terme pour le moment c'est
encore trop tôt pour savoir comment les
choses vont se dérouler mais on peut les
laisse la situation ne sera pas évidente
là maintenant on doit penser on doit on
doit faire le deuil des victimes
on doit soigner on doit soigner les
personnes blessées on doit chercher
encore les disparus et la question
maintenant de la reconstruction de la
zone qui a été détruite se posera après
franchissement
on ne dispose pas de ce financement
l'heure actuelle françois el bacha merci
pour votre témoignage bon courage à vous
surtout à je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et cofondateur du medad média
citoyen l'etna news merci